Alexi navarney has never been afraid to
stand up to Vladimir Putin but the
Russian opposition leaders activism has
come at a huge personal cost over the
last decade he has been attacked and
detained in 2020 he was poisoned with
the same nerve agent used in the
Salisbury poisonings miraculously he
survived but only thanks to the
treatment he received in a German
Hospital on return to Russia he was
jailed on charges he says were
politically motivated the European Court
of human rights has agreed demanding his
release but today he remains
incarcerated
now a documentary about Alexi navarney's
attempt to find out who poisoned him is
nominated for an Oscar and a bafta I've
been speaking to its director Daniel
rule about the impact of the film and
what we know now about Alexi navalny's
current condition
Daniel thank you for coming on the show
now your documentary about navani is
gripping it's moving it's quite an
extraordinary piece of work and an
extraordinary
story but fast can you explain to our
viewers where Alexi navarney is being
held what sort of facility he's in and
what shape he's in well first and
foremost thank you so much for having me
on the program it's great to be with you
here today and any opportunity to talk
about navalny is very meaningful for me
because the sad reality is that he's not
doing well unfortunately our film does
not have a happy ending right now
navalny is languishing in a penal colony
about six and a half hours outside of
Moscow he has been for most of the last
six months removed from the general
prison population and is instead
languishing in solitary confinement and
he is being held in what many
International observers will will say is
torturous conditions you know they it's
as if these these prison authorities
wake up every morning and ask themselves
how they can make this guy's life
miserable and it's important that your
viewers know the reason he's
specifically in solitary confinement
this is very important is because of his
anti-war or advocacy Alexa navalny is
the number one anti-war advocate in
Russia Today and that's why he's in
solitary confinement languishing do you
think that the start of the Ukraine war
intensified the brutality against Nevada
by the Russian authorities because of
this right I think the start of the
Ukraine war intensified the pressure not
just of only but all oppositionists all
uh uh political people with different
opinions all independent news outlets
navalny is one man but he seems to
represent hundreds if not thousands of
of uh independent Russians who have had
to sacrifice a great deal in opposition
of this war and Daniel
novani's supporters believe his life is
in grave danger right now how worried
are you about
whether he can survive
I'm extraordinarily worried it's it's
very scary you know he is in the custody
of the same men who tried to murder him
once what's stopping them from trying
again
it's it's
urgent it's vital the world needs to pay
attention to navalny we cannot forget
him that's how I frame the primary
responsibility of our documentary is to
provide the world with with a a vehicle
to get to know him and to learn about
his story there's also The Bravery of
his family who feature very heavily his
two children and his wife Yulia in the
documentary and they clearly are very
tight
loving family
um how are they bearing up do you
you presumed her in contact with the
family they must be missing their Dad
terribly I I think that
the the Dignity of Yulia navalny is such
that she keeps her cards pretty close to
her chest I think it's a Russian thing
but you can only imagine what it must be
like if your husband if your father is
in this horrible position this horrible
place you know he's not doing well you
know that he's being tortured that must
be
a burden that I can't even imagine that
certainly no College age or or high
school age students should have to
endure
um but the family like their father
has this remarkable courage when you
release the film and livoni was
imprisoned again did you fear the
consequences it release might have for
him or did you hope
that this amplification
of his story might actually give him
better protection or were you just not
sure
well
the film premiered three weeks before
this awful horrendous war in Ukraine
started and I think when the When The
War Began everyone was existing in this
ocean of uncertainty what's going to
happen What would stop these lunatics
from murdering navalny as they are
raining bombs down on this country in
Central Europe on Ukraine and so we
thought that we had to do we had a
responsibility to do whatever we could
to try and keep navalny's name in the
global Consciousness as a mechanism to
dissuade the regime from murdering him
and so we had this very fancy film
release plan you know films are released
at a very specific time there's lots of
planning that goes into their rollout
and their promotion we threw it all away
and instead we embarked on a uh
expedited get this film out into the
world as quickly as possible Mission and
the potential consequences of which we
were not concerned about What mattered
most to us was the security and safety
of navalny and if this film can move the
dial five or ten percent in dissuading
the regime for murdering him we
understood we had a responsibility to
get it out I guess the question office
followers from that donors if if they
tried to murder him once and now they
have him incarcerated why won't they
tried to murder him again I think it's
it's a it's a very fair question and
that's why I think nabalny is in a very
very scary position my working calculus
um I call it the the pain in the ass
index
they're sort of like is it more of a
pain in the ass for for the regime to
murder him or to instead let him
languish and what that speaks to is what
would the domestic response be how many
hundreds of thousands of people would
take to the streets would that
potentially be the straw that breaks the
camel's back and gets people engaged
gets people out into the streets and I
think the regime doesn't want to figure
that out so instead they say we'll let
him live but we will break his Spirit we
will break his body we will break his
well-being and we will let him languish
in the cell I would prefer of course
that he is freed and that he is reunited
with his family but more than anything
we just need him to survive this because
it's my opinion that his impact on the
future of Russia is unfulfilled and I
would like to see the day when he is
able to run in a free and fair
democratic election in the Russian
Federation and Daniel
arguably the most gripping part of the
film is when
navalny with the help of Christo is able
to identify suspects behind his
poisoning yeah and they find telephone
numbers I mean it's an incredible it's
hardly believable right it's so
extraordinary but you know they
essentially prank them these guys by
pretending to be A's to FSB agents and
get information about his poisoning and
you can't actually quite believe that
someone is just over the telephone
handing over this information can you
explain what happened on that day and
what you were thinking
when you are capturing that sure
navalny started the day
um just trying just as himself he'd get
a guy on the phone he'd say this is
navalny why'd you try and murder me and
then they'd hang up and it was not a
successful attempt and then at a certain
point someone decided I think Maria
suggested let's try it the prank way the
backup option where navalny would try
and impersonate a high-ranking FSB guy
and see if he could fool someone which
sounded as Outland just outlandish to me
then as it does now but they made the
first call then they made the second
call and the third call they called up
this campus called Constantine kudratsu
and I don't speak a word of Russian so
I'm just trying to intuitively figure
out where to put the camera but once
they got this guy on the phone I sort of
clocked out of the corner of my eye as
Maria pevchik yeah navali's Chief
investigator I saw her jaw unhinged and
hit the floor and I understood that
something extraordinary was happening
and you didn't have to speak a word of
Russian to know exactly what was going
down yeah
[Music]
foreign
foreign foreign
you say you say in the film that
afterwards you all say they're going to
kill him they're going to kill him when
they when we put this out what happened
to him you don't know well it's unclear
we thought for a while that he was dead
we thought that he had been disappeared
yeah it came into Focus about a year ago
I think Christo dug up uh a covid
database a database of covert tests and
his name was on it somewhere in Siberia
so we think he's alive but perhaps he
has been relegated to some terrible desk
job in the remote regions of Russia for
this horrible indiscretion he
perpetrated right at the end of the film
you ask him what is the message to the
Russian people
if they prison you will kill you
and he answers the question about if
they kill me this is the message and you
ask him to do it in Russian yeah and
it's the way into film and and he says
the only thing necessary for the Triumph
of evil is for good people to do nothing
so don't do nothing
the question I had as a viewer
afterwards was what was his answer about
if he was imprisoned because that became
his reality they didn't kill him but
they imprisoned him what did he answer
on that question well I don't remember
verbatim and had to look at the
transcripts
um but I would imagine that it was in a
very similar vein do not give up do not
look down he said something very
poignant we cannot look down we have to
look up and we have to we have to tackle
this thing head on these bad guys are
only able to exist if good people do
nothing so don't be inactive and that is
not just a call to Russian citizens
that's to call the Citizens all over the
world over the last 10 15 20 years we
have seen the rise of authoritarianism
take different Insidious forms and
proliferate to different pockets and
corners of the world that we thought
were immune to this type of this type of
instinct and what navalny is saying
doesn't just apply to Russia it applies
to to citizens all over the world
as his friend and as someone that has
worked him and knows him well on a
personal level do you wish he hadn't
gone back given what's happened because
that's how I ended the film I thought
don't go back
you know it's challenging to say first
off
I always wonder if his calculus would
have been different if he had a crystal
ball and knew that this war this
horrendous war was going to begin would
he have still gone back in that context
but the reality is we had no idea he he
had the information he had and he made
the decision he made it was a political
decision I think if you were here right
now what he might suggest is that
staying out of the country staying in
Exile would be too great a gift to the
Kremlin so he had to go back he wants to
be the moral leader of the nation and
and unfortunately for him that meant I'm
like sacrificing himself in this way
well done you thanks for coming in and
certainly the film has Amplified
historian and and you have managed to
get it nominated in the the biggest
theater yeah in the world which can only
be good good for him as well so thank
you so much for coming in and talking to
us about welcome thank you so much for
having me my I'm I'm sad that Alexa
navalny won't get to go to the Baptist
or the Oscars but he's with us in spirit
and any chance to talk about the film is
Meaningful so thank you Beth thank you
thanks so much appreciate it
well I hope you enjoyed this week's
conversation so I found both of them
absolutely fascinating now if you scan
this QR code on your screen now you can
watch all of our interviews online and
all the previous episodes of the show
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to Beth
Rigby interviews our podcast that's on
the Sky News app or wherever you get
your podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you so much to my guest Daniel raw and
Dex Hunter torik and thank you for
watching hope to see you next week
foreign
[Music]